I have good news today and it's rare
that I've had good financial news for
the program but I do have good news
today
earlier this week we talked about this
new fee structure that patreon rolled
out and patreon of course is this
platform that we use to raise money you
can pledge any amount of money that you
want on a monthly basis you can pledge a
dollar ten a hundred a thousand a
hundred thousand dollars if you wanted
nobody's done that but you could
conceivably I think it would work I
think the system would allow that
nobody's tried to the best of my
knowledge and what happened about five
six days ago is that patreon announced
that they would be changing the fee
structure so when you make a pledge of
five bucks to patreon we don't get the
full five dollars there's a fee that's
involved there and it depends on the
size of the pledge and a couple of other
factors and what patreon announced
earlier this week is that they were
gonna be shifting the burden of that fee
partially towards the donors in a way
that really wasn't good it wasn't a good
idea and to compound the disaster of
that their messaging around it was also
terrible unfortunately it was really bad
for us we lost over a hundred and fifty
or even close to 200 donors who were
understandably upset with the
announcement from patreon that I told
you about on Monday later in the week I
told you that there was Glee on YouTube
from haters as we highlighted on the
program thrilled that we were losing
money and had lost nearly 200 patrons I
highlighted some of those comments
yesterday followed by really good news
which is that patreon posted a blog post
yesterday and emailed creators deciding
that they are not going to make these
changes they titled their blog post we
messed up we are sorry and we're not
rolling out the fee changes this is a
very good thing I'm glad that patreon
has made this decision and part of it is
because people were cancelling their
pledges patreon clearly saw wow we made
this announcement and all of our
creators are starting to lose pledges
and that's a bad thing for them and
obviously it's bad for patrons business
as well now my concern is Pat people see
the article and they need never see the
correction right with newspapers this is
often the thing
big article in a newspaper that ends up
being something really bad and then five
days later on page twelve the newspaper
puts out a correction and nobody sees it
because they're either furious with the
newspaper and they're no longer getting
it anymore or they never read the page
12 right especially if they sign up for
patreon right and I get their newsletter
and really pull their support they don't
get that newsletter anymore they don't
see the update that's my concern that
the people who were still patrons were
notified that patreon has cancelled this
fee change but the people who canceled
their support are no longer receiving
emails from patreon and therefore they
would have absolutely no idea about it
so I'm here to tell you the changes are
canceled please come back and restart
those pledges and to make it extra
enticing I want to remind you we have
this patreon goal and you can see this
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
when we reach twenty two hundred and
fifty patrons we are going to record
edit and upload a multi-part critical
thinking miniseries initially it will be
distributed to patrons and then
eventually it will get full distribution
on YouTube this is a really really good
miniseries we've been working on for a
while I actually have for you today
provide some extra incentive to prove
that we're working on this I'm going to
show you the possible introduction that
producer Noah Ferguson has put together
for this video series and I get it that
if you're listening on the podcast or
the radio you're not going to see it
we are moving well ahead with this and
people will see that we've already got
graphics it looks really cool we're
developing a whole look for these I
believe that this is going to be one of
the coolest things and most most well
produced things that we do it will be a
twelve or so twelve to fifteen part
miniseries all about critical thinking
the patreon fee has been rolled back the
fee surge is done let's get to 20 250
patrons help us recover and then we'll
continue working on this critical
thinking miniseries which i think is
going to be absolutely fantastic so
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
one they cancelled the fee surge now
let's get those pledges restarted